The situation determines the type of greeting or introduction,...
...formal or informal, that you should use.
A ball game gives us an example of an informal greeting.
Hello, Johnny.
Hi, have I missed much of the game?
Only three to four minutes.
In some situations, with people that you know well, informal behavior is correct.
Even in informal introductions, a girl's name is usually mentioned first.
Kathy, this is my best friend Bruce.
Kathy is my cousin from Colorado.
How are you?
It's a good idea to supply some information about each person you are introducing.
You use the formal type of greeting or introduction in situations...
...that are outside your family or circle of very close friends.
For example:...
Dr. Phil, I want you to meet my son Stewart.
How do you do, Dr. Phil?
Hi, Stewart.
It's real nice to meet you, son.
Formal introductions are necessary in many situations.
Let's look at a few typical examples that you may encounter.
Suppose your school is having an open house for parents.
If your teacher and your parents have never met, it's up to you to make the introductions.
Hi Janet, how are you?
Fine.
Mrs. Stevens, I'd like you to meet my parents, Mr. and Mrs. Sanders.
How do you do?
It's proper to mention first the name of the person you wish to honor.
Since the teacher is outside of your family, her name is mentioned first.